one day after Lori Loughlin was arrested
for her alleged role in the college
bribery scandal the hammer has dropped
on her acting career and she's not the
only one in the family already paying
the price the fallout is fast and
furious hallmark announced they will no
longer work with Morrie she currently
has two projects with the network and
has done nearly 20 projects with them
over the course of her career as for her
YouTube star daughter and USC freshman
Olivia well today cosmetic chain Sephora
announced they are terminating their
sponsorship deal with her effective
immediately and her spring break was cut
short BAM
Bahamas Erika according to TMZ Olivia
and her girlfriends were in the Bahamas
on the yacht of billionaire Rick Caruso
his daughter is a friend of Olivia's
Rick also happens to be the chairman of
USC's Board of Trustees Caruso said
after operation varsity blues was
revealed
Olivia quote decided it would be in her
best interest to return home why do I
keep doing I don't like myself late
yesterday evening mom Lauri was released
from federal custody after posting a 1
million dollar bond the admission status
of both Olivia and her older sister
Isabella seen here last night hangs in
the balance
fine a rep for USC tells et the
University is conducting a case-by-case
review and a source close to the Lachlan
family tells ET the sisters are quote
devastated by their parents arrests and
quote it's been mortifying and
frightening for them they are so
painfully embarrassed that they don't
want to go outside they realize how
serious the charges are and feel
helpless being able to have you know a
fashion designer dad a mom who's an
actress you do feel like that gives you
a big leg up I feel like it definitely
gives us like both of us a leg up if I
can give them a leg up I absolutely
would the nepotism works and I have no
problems with it but unlike his wife
Felicity Huffman William H Macy was not
charged in the alleged scam
she's true against you and felicity
the indictment claims the
oscar-nominated actor knew about the
alleged scam however authorities claimed
he only took part in conversations and
wasn't as heavily involved as felicity
people who lie a little bit for a
greater cause are Co liars Wow
we are also getting more reaction out of
Hollywood and here's my favorite Chrissy
Teigen photoshopped her and her hubby
John Legend's faces on the soccer
players asking does this look real we
are trying to get into Harvard or if we
can always count on Chrissy can't wait
[Music]